why do we blame people why do we
why i mean i think about attitude that's
a lot of the you know you talk about
attitude a lot what um what is the what
is the source of that blame game we play
in our lives
well it goes very deep into human nature
right because the feeling that um i am
to blame causes all kinds of
self-reflections like what is what is it
about me that's wrong is there something
essentially wrong with me
so it's much easier to focus outward
we're not designed by the way our brains
are are created or wired to something
i'm going into for my next book we're
not wired to reflect on ourselves to
reflect on the brain itself to reflect
on our own functioning to reflect on our
own emotions
if you study neuroscience our emotions
are actually disguised from us we don't
see the source of them we may see the
source of a thought
sometimes but we never see the source of
our emotions like where does my anger
really come from so instead of focusing
inward on my anger really comes
from something in my childhood or from
something that happened a couple days
ago somebody said something we're going
to focus on the thing in front of us
that person said something they made me
angry they made me angry not i'm feeling
the anger right so we're wired to
continually look outward and see other
people as responsible for it and so
i wrote a book called the laws of human
nature which is my sixth book
and it's kind of long it's you know i
hate to say it's like 160 pages long i
don't want to discourage people from
reading it but i'm being honest
but i have like 18
laws in there about human nature and the
kind of negative qualities that we all
can have
narcissism
irrationality envy grandiosity
aggression on and on and on
and the point that i make in the book is
our tendency as human beings is to
always think that the other person has
these qualities
they're a narcissist right she's full of
envy he's aggressive but we never go
maybe i'm a narcissist maybe i have
narcissistic tendencies right
and i make the point in the book
that you are a human being that you were
born with the same brain that everybody
else is born with there are very few
differences between one human to another
in the brain functioning
and so to assume that you aren't
narcissistic is absurd it's wired into
our nature to be self-absorbed we're all
self-absorbed including myself and when
i wrote the book it was kind of painful
for me to realize
robert you actually are quite
narcissistic
but it's not natural for us to think
that way we want to always want to point
fingers at other people because that's
so much easier and we're creatures that
like the easy way out
i
have a theory and that's
human nature is to do the minimum and
everyone's minimum's different you know
my dad was pretty tough on me and you
know my minimum was different than
someone else who maybe didn't get
grounded for something and you know but
human nature is to do the minimum which
is why i feel like you see like you know
second and third generation kids within
wealthy families like the minimum gets
pretty low like there's a lot there's
you don't have to make make it yourself
there's a fallback this is definitely
part of the human condition to
um
to uh deflect and and protect ourselves
like i think that's kind of you know the
ego coming in again to negate against
pain um
are you saying that there's
an aspect of narcissism within everyone
an aspect of
a monster within everyone an aspect of
jealousy are you saying all we hold all
of these aspects it's just what we put
our
what makes what makes someone have more
narcissism or more anger or more
kindness what makes that pie get broken
up differently
well the i maintain well first of all
some narcissism there is a genetic
element to that no doubt and there's
also an element of early rearing right
your attachment theories how your
parents related to you so there is kind
of a background i'm not saying that
everyone's equally a narcissist there
are clearly what i call deep narcissists
and i have a kind of a kind of an image
that i've created
where let's say there's a at the high
point you are completely empathetic you
can get outside of yourself and think
completely of another person be as kind
i can get inside your mind
and at the bottom point at zero you were
completely 100 absorbed in yourself
right
most of us are at that kind of 50
line
right
and
if we get if painful things happen and
we're upset we can kind of dip below
that and become more self-absorbed if
we're happy and we're in a good mood and
we're in a relationship and things are
clicking we can get out of that and rise
up to 70 maybe 80 percent
some people
from very early age are locked into like
that 20 or 30
percentage position
because
they had parents who abandoned them who
didn't give them the proper attention
etc or they had parents who suffocated
them they didn't have the
the ability or the space to create a
solid sense of self
so when we're when we have experienced
some kind of painful situation
the first thing is we retreat inward
right that's our first instinct and we
want to protect ourselves right
but if you have no sense of self to
retreat into if it's kind of all
fragmented and you don't feel like there
is anything solid there you're gonna
your natural instinct is to get angry
people to find fault with them to attack
them to go into what's called
narcissistic rage etc
so
some people are at that lower point and
other people are higher in that case a
lot of it has to do
with childhood early childhood but the
key the point that i make in the book
that applies to all of the things you
mentioned all the laws is your degree of
self-awareness
so if you delude yourself and say no
i'm the one person on the planet that's
not a narcissist i'm the only person
ever created who doesn't have any of
these tendencies you can't correct
yourself right
you'll be at that position you'll be
locked through your whole life or you'll
keep dipping down
so the key is
no i have these tendencies i'm not a
deep narcissist like some of the people
we see in our own culture who are like
that right
okay but i have these tendencies i'm
aware of them now now i can begin to
catch them i can begin to see
in a conversation i'm not really
listening to the other person i'm
hearing my own thoughts i'm absorbed in
my own head right
so you need awareness
envy is an emotion that nobody wants to
admit to because it's a very ugly
admission it means i feel inferior to
you therefore i envy you
okay but envy is so natural we all feel
it i feel it 100 times during the course
of the day i tell people
somebody you know ryan holiday very well
my former men
yes okay thank you my
former mentee you know he's
becoming more successful than i ever was
you know he's outshining the master and
yes at moments i will feel envy for his
youth for his success for his family etc
but i'm aware of it and therefore my
awareness gives me the power to say
robert that envy is an ugly emotion you
don't want to feel it let's change it
into something else
so i i hope i'm answering your question
i think okay
i think it leads to the next good
question which
i think is challenging
how the question is how do we
create awareness of ourselves
and i think it's tricky because first
off people don't even know to
to even want awareness like i think
people can generalize and say that like
um yeah i'm aware like i mean i went to
work and this guy was a jerk and then i
came you know and like food was dick
cold and i don't know whatever i'm just
making up a story but i don't think
anyone would not it's almost like being
healthy i feel like everyone could say
like yeah i want to be healthy but
nobody really knows not everyone knows
how to do it and i feel like awareness
is similar in the sense that i think
people want awareness but i don't know
if they know how to get it
well it's what you said earlier where we
want the easy path i call it the line of
least resistance we take the line of
least persistence
so
if we weren't aware that exercise can
actually make us feel better and get us
healthier when we go to the gym we would
just do the little the tiniest little
bit of movement and then go home and
have a beer and think wow we exercise
today but we're aware that you have to
do more of it
that you have to build up your muscles
that over the period of weeks and months
of going to the gym
of lifting weights of swimming and
running you're going to build up
straight and it's going to get better
and better and better okay
awareness is a muscle
it's not literally a muscle it's a
mental muscle let's just use an image
here right
so if you just go yeah i'm aware okay
enough story over
it's never going to happen it's like
going to the gym you have to practice it
every day you have to have it has to
become a habit all right so that's the
first thing for you just to get down on
your hands and knees and go
i am not aware of myself
i am deluding myself in most situations
it's a come to jesus moment you admit
that you are not aware that you're not
practicing this okay now you can go to
the next step
and then and i tell this like a lot in
the daily laws but in all of my books
it's a process there are baby steps that
you go along the way and the hardest
thing for people is to detach themselves
from themselves and that's the main
power i'm trying to give you in my books
the ability to look at yourself with
some distance and detachment and observe
yourself in action
so you begin by let's say tomorrow we're
going to start this process i heard
robert and i'm going to start it
tomorrow okay
i want you just one time during the day
to catch yourself feeling an emotion
right
anger envy love excitement whatever it
is
and to step back
and just for a couple of minutes to try
and analyze that emotion and go
where does it really come from is it
really just love or excitement or is it
maybe something else
is it maybe a mix of emotions is it
maybe the opposite sometimes when we
hate somebody we actually love them
weird but that's how perverse people can
be right
take that step back
and go what's really going on here maybe
write it down in a journal all right
you've taken one step in one day and now
the whole thing will start opening up to
you because you'll see
you'll realize in that moment that
you're continually reacting to emotions
and never analyzing them and it gets you
in trouble
you you send that you send that angry
email and you go the next day what the
hell did i do that was so stupid i can't
take it back how embarrassing
day in and day out you're reacting i
want to give you the power to stop
reacting
you go
well that's right i was feeling
excitement in that moment i stepped back
i analyzed it and actually that
excitement was a feeling of envy a
feeling of insecurity it really isn't
what i thought it was
that's interesting now that gives me the
power to maybe
i don't want you to repress your
emotions because that doesn't work
emotions are very important for us for
our functioning
but awareness of them aware of where
they come from where of your own faults
aware of the own patterns in your life
that bring trouble is extremely
important from those small steps we can
build it out something larger like i
mentioned seeing the patterns in your
life which is an extremely powerful
powerful bit of perception
because
if you know if i was fired once for
outshine the master but as i say in my
books for human beings nothing ever
happens once
there's always a pattern
if somebody if somebody does something
kind of rotten to you then they go oh
danica that wasn't me i don't know what
something came over me that's not really
who i am and you okay well maybe that's
true uh-uh that is who they are you can
bet your dog a dollar on it they've done
that many many times before nobody ever
does anything once we're habitual
creatures
i don't mean never but usually yeah so
i have patterns that outshine the master
was a pattern of mine
and if you now can take that little
distancing thing and go from my emotions
to what are the patterns in my life who
are the bad people i've gone into
relationships with before which is all a
very common pattern you suddenly are
getting more and more power over your
phobia all activities man you're
suddenly getting more and more power
over yourself so that's
it's a process it's like going to the
gym it's going to take a couple years
and it'll bring you peace
it will bring you self-understanding it
will bring you better relationships in
life it'll make your workplace you will
have less emotion and less drama which i
think we all of us need
[Music]